[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN MCCLENDON: And
there it goes.
Hi.
My name is Brian McClendon, and
I'm in charge of Google
Maps, Earth, and Street
View and the
other Google Geo products.
I'd like to welcome you here
today to talk about what's new
in Google Maps.
But to start with, I need to
talk about some history.
Hic sunt dracones.
This is what they wrote on old
maps when they were drawing
them and they didn't know
where the borders were.
It was to tell the people
looking the maps--
don't go there, you might
fall over the cliff.
But our goal at Google has been
to try to remove as many
dragons from your maps as
possible and make it possible
for both our billion users and
all of the developers to have
as few dragons as possible.
To do this--
we go forward--
the three principles at Google
Maps are comprehensiveness,
accuracy, and usability.
And this is what we do whenever
we think about what
projects we're going to work
on and how we're going to
improve our data and our
user experience.
So the first is
comprehensiveness.
Google has been working on
crawling the web for years.
And as they were crawling the
web, they were getting more
and more data.
In maps, in GEO here, we are
collecting as much data as we
possibly could.
And so comprehensiveness and
completeness has always been
part of the product.
But in the early days
we started here.
This is the first Google
Maps in 2005.
And it was really a revelation
of the time because before
then, you saw that map
providers would, when
[INAUDIBLE] request, they would
render a map and it
would take 10 seconds.
You'd go pan and zoom and it
would be another 10 seconds
you'd have to wait.
It was good at the time.
The Internet was amazing
at maps, but we
felt we could do better.
And so we invented several
things to make
Google Maps in 2005.
The biggest one was, we decided
to pre-render the map.
We took all of the map data
for the world and baked it
into map tiles, many of which
you're very familiar with, and
set it up so that we can serve
them very, very quickly.
And this changed
the interaction
model for user maps.
The dragging and zoom
was very fast.
We also simplified the
search box up there.
The single search box is much
better than the two, three, or
six entry search box
in the past.
So getting this product, it was
amazing, but it was limiting.
So this was our first actual
world map in 2005.
And you'll notice that's not a
mistake-- that we actually
didn't have Western Europe, we
didn't have Central and South
America, or pretty much anywhere
else in the world.
There were, in fact,
dragons on our map
in that first launch.
And we spent time improving
the map.
And by 2007, we had basically
the whole world covered.
But there was still skeletal
little holes, countries where
we had the basics, but we didn't
have in-depth data.
However, by 2008, we did have
licensed data for the entire
world and were able to show
a good world map.
But it just the beginning.
Imagery.
Coming from Keyhole, we were
acquired by Google in 2005,
our goal was to get as much
satellite and aerial imagery
as possible.
And we worked on that project
at Keyhole for many years--
pushing hard drives around.
When we got to Google,
they gave us 1,000
servers and we started.
Larry signed a check for
digital globe data, and
suddenly we had a large
amount of satellite.
We were very excited about what
we'd achieved from the
launch of Google Earth
in 2005 to 2006.
And we had covered 37% of the
world's population with
high-res imagery.
That was great, but there's a
long way from there to making
everybody happy.
Because the main question
everybody asked when they
would look at Google Maps
and Google Earth was,
can I see my house?
And the goal in 2012, we now
have over five billion people
who can say the answer
yes to that question.
And today, every two weeks, we
push as much data as the
entire database was in 2006.
Another project, Street
View, started in 2007.
We published five cities with
this panorama imagery--
about four and a half
megapixel panoramas.
And it was a great hit.
Everybody loved this
virtual tourism.
They would jump in and drive
down the street, and it was
very exciting, but it was
just the beginning.
And we took this project and
greatly expanded it.
By 2012, we have 39 countries,
3,000 cities plus, we've
driven over 5 million
unique miles.
We now have data in all
seven continents.
The seventh one was added in
Antarctica by me in 2010.
And so I actually went and took
these pictures with a
standard camera with a fish-eye
lens and gave it to
the Street View team, and they
added half of an island on the
Antarctic Peninsula.
But we've just started there.
We actually have some good
handle on getting even more
Street View data in
Antarctica, so
that's pretty cool.
However that project, while
grand in scope and has taken a
lot of our time, led us to
think of something even
bigger, which was to
build our own maps.
In 2008, we were somewhat
dissatisfied with the data
that we were able to license.
It was not as accurate as we
liked, and we couldn't update
it very quickly-- sometimes
taking three months to a year
to get updates through
the system.
And so we started embarking on
creating our own map data
using government data-- any data
that we could license in
and bring in to make part
of our own maps--
but basing it on Street View
and the power of having
ground-level checks on a lot
of this location data.
We called the project
Ground Truth.
And this is an example.
This is a screen shot
of our internal
tool to make the maps.
And you can see, we combine
Street View GPS tracks.
We combine Street
View imagery.
We took road data.
We took the orthographic imagery
that we had from all
over the place.
And we used Computer Vision to
extract data from Street View.
So you can see pictures here of
like the 101 sign, also a
speed limit sign down there
on the bottom right.
We would actually extract
those and show those to
operators, so they could improve
the attributes and
correct and detect issues as
we were going through and
making our own map data.
And this led to incredibly
high quality maps that we
launched, initially, in the
United States in 2009.
In parallel, we use Map Maker.
So GT was a great story for the
developed world where we
had Street View data
and so on.
But a lot of the maps were
completely blank.
As you saw at the beginning of
this video, in 2008, there was
nothing in Faisalabad,
Pakistan.
And over four years, they've
taken a blank map and turned
it into one of the best maps
of any city that I know of.
This is all with local knowledge
and people who are
passionate about making maps.
And Map Maker has allowed people
all over the world to
add and improve data and add
to the comprehensiveness in
Google Maps.
And so, countries like Pakistan,
Romania, Vietnam,
Philippines--
by far the best maps anybody's
ever had are
currently in Map Maker.
So 2008, we were
licensed data.
Today in 2012, we have 187
countries with driving
directions, which is sort of our
min bar for claiming that
we have good data coverage.
26 million miles of
navigable roads.
You can see the contributions
of Google-sourced imagery,
Google-sourced data, and the
user data, along with still
some countries that
we do license.
Accuracy.
Making that data useful
and correct has been a
challenge for us.
There's a lot of ways to
introduce error and a lot of
ways to fix them.
My philosophy in building maps
at Google has been that
combining all this data together
and figuring out how
to make it improve each other
is a critical part.
If you look at this here, we
have terrain data that we
actually generated from
imagery at times.
We have map data.
We have Street View.
We have the GPS tracks from
Street View, the imagery from
Street View.
We have the orthographic
imagery and now this 3D
imagery that Peter
will talk about.
All combine, and if you think
about it as a collection of
semi-accurate data, you can use
the different layers to
correct each other.
You can find out how the roads
align with the imagery, how
the terrain aligns
with the roads.
You can see how the 3D building
data aligns with the
road data, so the overpasses--
are they in exactly
the right place.
All of this leads to a much
more accurate map.
And on top of that, we have
our local data, the local
businesses and POIs.
And the ability to correctly
place those across the map
makes us a much better
map story.
But we're still working on it
because there's so many
different things we can do.
As an example, here's
Street View.
Here's some of the stuff that
we do, both manually and
automatically.
Computer Vision is able to
pick out street signs and
business names, also pick out
speed limits, detect whether
it's a bicycle lane or not.
And what Computer Vision can't
do, it can provide data to our
operators to continue
to improve the map.
But there's other
ways to do it.
We use our users.
Report a Problem--
it is very popular in both
desktop Google Maps and GMM.
If a user sees a problem--
they don't like a direction
they're given because they
pretty much know that
it's wrong--
they can report it and
send it to us.
We then take that report to
our operators who use this
very customized, back-end tool
that has much more access to
our database.
And can look to see, not only
what our data shows on the
public map, but all of our
internal data structures with
a very high quality Street View
navigator that allows a
user to very quickly compare
what the user said to what we
see in Street View.
So if it matches in that way,
we're done, it's easy.
But if it doesn't match, we'll
go and investigate further
using whatever means possible.
And the result is we get a much
more high quality map.
But there's some reports we
can't do anything with.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN MCCLENDON: Map Maker is
launched in 10 new countries
in the month of June.
So we are also using Map Maker
to improve our high quality,
developed world maps.
And so people can add hiking
trails, biking trails, and
make the same kind of
corrections that
our operators do.
And it goes through a moderation
pipeline, and we
can validate and publish the
data very, very quickly.
Usability--
it's all great to have great
data but only if you can get
good access to it.
So I talked to you a little bit
about the single box, but
I want to talk a lot more
about it because it's, I
think, one of the biggest
challenges we have.
And a lot of our engineers spend
a huge amount of time
figuring out what to
do with your query.
We have a geo-coding database,
that's easy.
Figuring out how to parse it out
and make the best answer
for a user's intended question
is very hard.
We have to deal with different
languages, right to left, left
to right, Arabic, Chinese,
Japanese--
all very difficult.
We have to deal with
partial addresses--
a city name, street
name, without a
state or anything else.
We can guess based
on proximity.
Searching for category,
searching for specific
navigation, businesses--
finding those.
Also being able to turn on and
off traffic and doing driving
directions, all from
the single box.
The ability to take the user's
action and, in as many cases
as possible, get it right the
first time is very powerful.
In addition, we have
Autocomplete down
there at the bottom.
This provides not
just guesses--
what we think you want--
but suggestions of different
things you can do with Google
Maps today.
And some of these features, we
have them in the API, but Thor
is going to tell you a lot
more in the near future.
Another part of usability is
giving good performance and
delivering.
We announced recently, one
billion monthly, active GeoMap
services users.
And to deliver that kind of
service reliably, over the
past three years our tile
servers have had greater than
four nines reliability.
We don't have scheduled down
time at Google, so that's 26
minutes a year.
We have 1.6 million QPS peak
tile serving right now, but we
can probably go higher.
All from eight data centers
which give you low latency no
matter where you are.
However, that power allows us to
do some really cool things.
I told you before that one of
our innovations in 2005 was to
pre-render the map tiles.
And that really greatly
increased the speed.
But over time, we've had some
crazy ideas where we could
actually render the map
tiles on demand.
And doing so actually gave
us great improvements.
Now you may not have noticed
because they're still raster
map tiles when they come to you,
but the fact is that we
render everything on demand.
So road traffic is
a good example.
Most people who do road traffic
will do an overlay
raster on top of the map data.
And what that means is that it
obscures some part of the map.
We're able to actually bake
the road data into the map
tile correctly layered under
the road labels.
Better user experience--
that's just one small thing.
We have several more--
maps in your language,
translated tiles.
When you ask for map data, we'll
give it to you the best
we can based on who you are.
In the API, we had
styled maps.
And many of you are familiar
with this, the ability to
render specific styles to match
your website, match
nighttime needs, whatever
it takes.
But the biggest thing, and
really the reason that drove
us to do it, was the ability to
publish map fixes instantly.
And so once the moderators
approve an edit, you'll see
these edits go live within five
minutes or less worldwide.
And so that ability is what
makes us able to turn and
correct maps and produce
maps in new
countries very, very quickly.
So we have 800,000 developers
or more working at
Google Maps API today.
And the amazing things they've
achieved, amazing things
you've achieved, have given us
all sorts of inspiration, but
we're continuing to grow.
We think Google Maps API is
a critical part of our map
service, and even today, year
over year, it's greatly
increasing in use, counter
argument to some reports you
might have read.
But with that, I would like to
introduce Thor Mitchell who is
going to talk about new features
in Google Maps API.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
THOR MITCHELL: OK.
OK, good afternoon everybody.
As Brian said, my name's
Thor Mitchell.
I'm a product manager based in
the Sydney office focused on
the Google Maps API and
the Google Places API.
Today I'm going to give you a
preview of some of the new
features that we're bringing to
these APIs for you, here at
I/O this year.
Before we go into that though,
I just want to emphasize how
much of what I'm about to show
you has been driven by you.
Your feedback is very
important to us.
And we connect with developers
in many different ways, such
as through sponsor tags on Stack
Overflow, through events
like this, and through our
regular office hours Hangouts.
One of the most useful tools we
have for understanding your
needs is our Issue Tracker.
So if you're not familiar with
our Issue Tracker, this is a
site you can go to to tell us
the features that you're
looking for and express interest
in ideas that others
have added for features
you'd like to see.
And as you'll see as
we go through, we
take this very seriously.
And if there's one takeaway from
this session I'd like you
to have, it's to make good
use of this tool.
So let's begin with
the Places API.
Now if you were with us
at I/O last year,
you may recall that--
I think possibly in this very
room, at this very time--
we announced the broad
availability of the Google
Places API.
If you're not familiar with the
Google Places API, it's
our developer offering for
access to our worldwide corpus
of local business listings,
points of interest, and
landmark data.
At its heart, the Places
API is very simple.
You provide us with a location,
you provide us with
a radius, and we'll
give you back the
20 best places nearby.
And to tailor these results to
your specific application, you
can filter based on one of over
100 globally consistent,
high level categories
such as restaurants.
You can also provide specific
keywords to focus in on
particular types of business,
such as a cuisine, or a
particular type of clothes
store, or such like.
Another feature of the Places
API that we launched last year
is Autocomplete.
Now Brian's touched on this
briefly already, but this
essentially brings that
type-ahead search
functionality that you see
on Google Maps into your
applications.
And Autocomplete is particularly
useful when
dealing with those infuriating,
multi-field
address forms that litter
the internet.
There's no reason you should
have to force your users to
enter their details in all these
different fields over
and over again.
You can give them one, single
text field, they can just
type, we will complete
the address for them.
And then we'll give you the
structured address components
that your application needs.
It's such, such a better
user experience.
Once you have used this, every
site you come across that asks
you to enter an address that
doesn't use it, it
just drives you crazy.
OK, so there's nothing new
here, what is new?
Well as I mentioned earlier, one
of the things that we take
very seriously is
your feedback.
And when we took a look at the
Issue Tracker for the Places
API, there's one issue that has
been way out in front in
terms of the amount of requests
we've had for it
since the day we launched--
that's access to
Google Reviews.
So I'm happy to say that,
starting today, when you use
the Places API to get detailed
information about a business,
we'll return to you the top five
reviews for that place as
shown on Google+ Local.
So, if you take a look at
Google+ Local and look at a
specific review, you'll notice
that there are-- it's made up
of certain elements.
There's the text of the review,
there's the scores the
reviewer gave, and there's also
information about who
submitted that review--
if they have a
public Google+ profile.
All of this information is now
returned in the Places API.
You may also know that if you
log into the Google+ Local as
an a signed-in Google+ user,
there's some additional
information available to you
that is provided by Zagat.
This includes scores across
three aspects of the business.
And those aspects vary
depending on
the class of business.
So for a restaurant, it's decor,
food, and service.
There's also the editorial
review which is a
human-crafted summary of the
best reviews that we've
received for that business.
Now we're working on a new
option for our Maps for
Business customers that allow
you to get access to this
Zagat content as well.
So if that's something that
might be interesting to you,
please do contact the Maps
for Business sales team.
So up to now, the Places API has
been really very focused
on mobile, location-based
apps.
And these apps have
one big advantage.
They have access to a
fine-grained location signal
for the user based on GPS.
And that allows us to give
you an easy way of
searching near the user.
However, we recognize there are
many use cases for local
data which would benefit more
from the sort of a single,
one-box usability experience
that Brian mentioned.
And so we're bringing that
to the Places API today.
So now you can let your users
express their searches just in
simple text in any way they
like, and we will
interpret it for you.
You can see that this could
be a what/ where query.
This could be a query that just
contains a category, and
then we use the map to
infer the location.
But also, it's just a single
address or a single business.
So it's a very flexible model.
Users can just say what
they're looking for.
You all know this, you're
familiar with it from Google
Maps, but we're bringing that
into the API as well.
We're also extending the
existing Autocomplete
functionality to be able to
suggest possible queries as
you type, as well as the places
it suggests today.
So that's all I'm going to cover
on the Places API for
this morning.
However, it's not the end of the
announcements we have for
the Places API.
And if you'd like to hear more,
I recommend the session,
Building a Business Around the
Google Places API, that is
happening next door towards
the end of today.
Marcelo is our engineering lead
for the Places API, and
Andres manages our developer
relations team for Maps.
OK, so now we will move
on to the Maps API.
Now, as some of you may know,
the Maps API has been through
a significant transition
in the last few years.
Back in 2009 at Google I/O, we
introduced version 3 of the
Google Maps API.
And a year later, it became our
primary Google Maps API.
And since then, we've been
working to bring over features
from v2 that people value
into the Maps API v3.
And along the way, we've also
attempted to make improvements
where we can and also
bring new features.
And there are many advantages
to Maps API v3 as a result.
Now we reached a significant
milestone earlier this year
when we moved the last of the
v2 features that we want to
bring into v3 over.
Which means that if you're
continuing to maintain or
develop a v2 application, now
really is the time to go and
make the migration.
Especially as the end of the v2
application period is now
less than a year way.
So what's new in Maps?
Well when we sat down and
tried to think about how
should we figure out what we
should develop that would be
new for you, we really realized
there were two key
questions that had
to be answered.
Firstly, what do developers
want?
What is it you're looking
for in this service?
What can we offer you
that will help you?
What do you need?
Secondly, what could we do
that would be awesome?
What could we do that would be
new, innovative, maybe not
something you thought of, but
something that would have
broad appeal.
Something that would really
increase the capabilities of
the Maps API to meet
its goals.
And in doing that, we had to
answer questions like, what is
the Maps API for?
What is its purpose?
So, I'm going to touch on one
feature from each of these two
categories this morning.
Firstly, what do developers
want?
Well, once again this is easy
for us to determine.
We simply go to the Issue
Tracker and we take a look.
And if you look at the Issue
Tracker for the Maps API, you
discover that one feature--
across all of our APIs-- has
been way out in front for a
couple of years now.
Which is why I'm very happy to
say that today we're bringing
Google Transit to
the Maps API.
[APPLAUSE]
THOR MITCHELL: So we're
introducing Transit to the
Maps API in two ways.
Firstly, we are adding the
Transit layer, which allows
you to visualize the transit
network for a city
on top of your map.
Secondly, we're adding support
for Transit as a travel mode
in the Directions API in
the Direction Service.
So you can route across
public transport.
OK, so that's something
that developers want.
What about something new?
So when we were thinking about
something new, we--
as I mentioned, we asked
ourselves, what is the goal of
the Maps API?
And really the Maps API, unlike,
say, Google Maps which
is about navigation, it's about
finding businesses, it's
about understanding the
world around you.
The Maps API is about you.
It's about your data, it's about
your stories, it's about
the message you want
to get across.
And so we wanted to find ways to
help you do more flexible,
interesting visualizations of
your data in the Maps API.
But once again, the inspiration
for where we ended
up actually started with
our Issue Tracker.
Because we saw this--
polylines with arrows.
That seems easy.
I mean, you take an arrow, you
stick a triangle on the end.
How hard can it be?
Well, it turns out there's
some complexity to this.
You see, what happens
if you move the map?
Our maps are panable, they're
dragable, you can zoom in, you
can zoom out.
That arrowhead soon goes out of
view and then you lose all
about directional context.
And what about the shape
of the arrowhead?
I mean, there are a lot
of different ways
you can draw an arrowhead.
This is just a small sample of
the 130 different arrowheads
that are in the Unicode spec.
And we didn't think necessarily
that trying to
give you a canned set
was sufficient.
We wanted to give you
more flexibility.
So we think it may be better if
we let you define the shape
of the arrowhead yourself.
But if we're going to let you
define the shape of the
arrowhead, why stop
at arrowheads?
So today, we're introducing
a simple--
a new simple but powerful new
concept into the Maps API.
And we call it symbols.
A symbol is an icon, much like
an existing marker image that
you might use today.
But it is defined as a vector.
And it's rendered by the
browser in the client.
The consequence of this is that,
firstly, as a vector, it
can be re-sized easily without
any loss in quality.
And secondly, that you can
control in your application,
how it's styled--
its stroke, its fill, its
opacity, et cetera.
Critically, not only can you
control how it's styled, you
can change how it's styled--
dynamically.
So to give you an example of the
value of this, I'd like to
show you a Maps application that
uses symbols as a marker
rather than the existing
marker images.
A few years ago, Walmart
released a data set that
included a list of all of their
stores and the dates at
which those stores opened.
So what we're doing here is
simply visualizing that
expansion of the Walmart chain
over time in the US.
Now you can see that we
represent each store with a
small, red dot.
That's a symbol.
We also use another circle
around the dot to indicate
when the store has opened.
That's another symbol but a
symbol that we grow, and we
changed the opacity to fade
it away over time.
What you may also notice is that
we're not done with dots
once we plotted them.
As time passes, we change the
color to illustrate how long
that store's been open.
And so you can see visually, not
just as an animation but
through color, how the
distribution of stores across
the US occurred over time.
Just let it run because
it's quite pretty.
So this is an example of using
a symbol as a marker.
But what about those
arrowheads?
Isn't that where we started?
So as well as just using symbols
as markers, you can
also use symbols to decorate
polylines.
So you can see here, I'm
using drawing tools.
And this particular line has an
arrowhead attached to it I
can also configure the
arrowheads to be repeated
along the line to address the
problems I mentioned earlier.
And there's a couple of
different ways of doing this.
In this case, I've set it so
that the arrowhead density
remains constant as you
zoom in and out.
Of course, it's not just
arrowheads, you can use any
symbol to decorate a polyline
in this way.
Here's a few examples of the
sort of symbols you might use.
And what you'll notice is that
the symbol styling is
independent of the polyline
styling it's attached to.
Which raises an interesting
possibility because we can
just hide the polyline.
And then we get to implement
another feature developers
have asked us for--
dotted lines and dashed lines.
Now these lines are straight
just because it fitted neatly
on the slide, but the symbols
will follow the shape of your
line, even if the line
is geodesic.
What's interesting is that, in
much the same way that I said
to you that the symbol
properties relating to the
style of the symbol can be
dynamically modified by your
application, so too can the
rules on how the symbols are
rendered on the line, where
they're rendered on the line--
which imagine you do
things like this.
[APPLAUSE]
THOR MITCHELL: Now when I saw
this, I got quite excited.
And I reached out to a colleague
of mine who works on
our flight search team and I
said, do you have any good
data on flights?
He said, we have all the
data on flights.
[LAUGHTER]
THOR MITCHELL:And he sent me
a file that contained the
schedule for every single
commercial flight on the
planet today--
from every airport, to every
airport, what time it leaves,
what time it arrives, what type
of plane it is, whether
they serve food.
So using that, and combining it
with the Maps API support
for geodesic polylines
and symbols, I was
able to build this.
This demo shows--
or will show, I hope,
in a second--
come on, going backwards
for some reason.
Here we go.
This demo shows every arrival
and departure from San
Francisco Airport
happening today.
Each of these--
you can see the curfew lifts
at six and boom.
[LAUGHTER]
THOR MITCHELL: Every single
plane on this map is simply a
symbol attached to a geodesic
polyline that runs from the
origin to destination.
I don't have to worry about how
to calculate the location
of these planes.
I simply set a percentage offset
along that polyline
based on the difference between
the departure and
arrival time.
The Maps API does everything
else for me.
We even go as far as calculating
these distances,
these percentage distances,
along geodesics in meters to
make sure these positions
are accurate.
So this is, I think, a simple
concept that really powers up
our data visualization
capabilities.
But it's not the only data
visualization feature that
we're launching at I/O today.
However--
oh, this really is going
backwards now--
I know it's nice but
we've seen it.
However, I sadly
am out of time.
So I recommend you attend our
next session, which is right
next door immediately after
this one on spatial data
visualization.
And with that, I'd like
to hand over to
my colleague Dylan.
He's going to talk a
little bit about
our Enterprise efforts.
DYLAN LORIMER: Hello, my name
is Dylan Lorimer and I'm a
product manager at
Google on the
Enterprise Geospatial team.
And our mission on that team
is to make it incredibly
simple for any business or
government or enterprise
organization to use our
geospatial technology in the
context of their everyday,
business decision-making.
And we see all kinds of really
interesting, varied use cases
of our technologies--
everything from the prototypical
store locator on
the web, to fleet tracking and
asset tracking solutions,
disaster response, humanitarian
response-- maps
that serve a great purpose
in this world.
We have organizations managing
their entire catalog now of
GIS data, or geospatial
data, in our cloud.
We see maps embedded in planes,
maps embedded in all
kinds of vehicles, and then
all sorts of third party
software vendors embedding
our maps and our
services in their products.
Our goal is to make this all
possible on the Enterprise
Geospatial team.
And really the common
thread across these
use cases is data.
Businesses and governments tend
to want to take their own
mapping data and put it on top
of Google Maps, or bring it
into Google Earth,
or distribute
it to mobile devices.
And these businesses and
governments tend to have their
own types of data really
specific to what they do--
sometimes different data than
what Google would publish on
its Basemap.
So for instance, private floor
plan data or data pertaining
to the infrastructure for
their jurisdiction--
might be more current imagery
or kind of false color or
derived imagery data sets.
Whatever it is, it's really
specific to how they conduct
their business day to day.
And historically, it's actually
really difficult, we
found, for governments and
businesses to be able to take
that data and actually
put it on the map.
It's required a costly
investment in on premise
hardware, expensive software
licenses, dedicated
administration, specialists
to manage the data.
It just hasn't been that easy.
Google, on the other hand,
we built a lot of great
Infrastructure over the years.
Brian kind of talked
about all of it.
Great infrastructure, really
in support of our consumer
mission for Google Earth and
Google Maps, to take all the
relevant, geospatial data in
the world and provide it to
our consumer users to meet and
surpass their expectations for
the best, most authoritative
data.
We built this great
infrastructure, and we
recognize that businesses
and governments could
benefit from it.
Why couldn't we provide them
with access to this cloud
platform, essentially,
or these tools to
process their own data.
And so we did that.
We launched Google Maps Engine
earlier this year-- really
late last year-- earlier
this year.
And that's Google's GeoCloud
Platform, enabling businesses
and governments, and anyone to
upload their mapping data to
Google's Cloud, whether it be a
spreadsheet containing their
store locations, could be some
shape files or other data sets
pertaining to the Basemap, could
be terabytes of imagery.
Whatever it is, upload
it to Google's Cloud.
Securely manage it in our Cloud,
and then get access to
our processing technology
to build maps and
build layers with it.
And then publish those to your
users who could access it
through simple-to-use desktop
applications like Google Earth
client, or a Google Maps-like
interface, or Google Earth on
mobile devices.
Or also expose it to developers
to embed in their
own third party products.
That's Google Maps
Engine today.
We launched it as an
Enterprise product.
It still is an Enterprise-only
product and we do intend,
later in the year, to provide
for an online trial that folks
can try out online without
having to speak
to our sales team.
And we're really thrilled
with the use to date.
We are actually now serving--
this is in addition to what
Google serves on its Basemap--
we're now serving through Maps
Engine almost 170 terabytes of
customers' own data.
This is data they've uploaded,
raster data.
This is raster data they've
uploaded to Maps Engine and
they're serving securely to
their users, whether it's
their customers, their
employees, their constituents,
or the public at large.
Whoever it is, it's their data
in Google's Cloud served out
through our technology.
Almost 3 billion features--
vector features of data-- that
are hosted in our cloud and
rendered into tiles on demand
for use in their mapping
applications.
And we're now seeing greater
than 1,000 private maps from
our customers published
to their own users.
So we're really thrilled
with the usage to date.
And also really excited about
what we have in store.
So for the past four or six
months since launch, we've
really been focused on a few key
areas of innovation based
largely on customer feedback
and what we're excited to
bring to market.
Rich API to the platform is, by
and large, the thing we've
heard that most of our
customers have
requested from day one.
So we're going to talk a little
bit about APIs today
and then also some next
generation ways to visualize
the data, sort of in line with
what Thor had demonstrated
with the Maps API.
But by far, the number one
feature request from our
customers has been programmatic
access to the
Maps Engine Platform.
Our users want to be able to
programmatically upload data,
download data, build maps,
process imagery, publish maps,
query data sets, append
features--
have a full set of programmatic
capabilities to
our platform.
And so today I'm delighted to
announce that, a little bit
later this year, pretty soon,
we're going to release to all
Maps Engine customers, in sort
of a trusted, testing
capacity, this first release
of the APIs.
And the APIs really offer
two broad categories of
capability--
programmatic data upload, data
query, the ability to find
data sets available to you as
a user, the ability to build
layers and so forth.
And then also kind of vector
crud-type operations--
sort of queries, appends,
edits, and inserts into
individual vector data sets.
So for instance, if you had a
set of store locations, you
could query those stores to
find stores that were open
between 10:00 AM and
9:00 PM that had a
handicap ramp, for instance.
So we're excited about
these APIs.
They'll be available soon to
our Maps Engine customers.
And I thought it would be
helpful to actually make this
a little more concrete, to
actually talk to an existing
application built
on Maps Engine.
So this is by one of our
partners in Vista.
They built a utilities
management mapping application
they provide to cities to help
them get an understanding of
what's going on below
their city streets.
And the capabilities here that
sort of articulate what the
APIs will provide is
that users log in.
Based on their identity,
they get access
to different layers.
You actually see a premium image
being distributed from
GeoEye, who also use Maps
Engine, right into the
application.
Users can restyle layers based
on mouse clicks and events.
They can get a tabular view of
the attributes, based on other
kinds of queries.
And then even do more advanced
things like buffer lines or do
intersections.
So this is just a good example
of the sort of prototypical
application that we expect a lot
of folks to build on these
Maps Engine APIs.
The other area we've been
focused on is this next
generation of visualization
of your data in the cloud.
Thor spoke at length about the
opportunity with modern
browser technology for
client-side rendering of
Google's data.
And that's also, of course,
possible with customers' data
stored in Maps Engine.
So I'm going to jump
into a video here.
But what you're going to see is
that polygons for countries
of the world are sent
to the browser.
The developer, in JavaScript,
has structured access to them
and they can choose how
to render them.
In this case, based on temporal
characteristics.
They can style them a certain
way and create a time series.
And this is just a really
basic example of what's
possible, but really anything's
possible when, on
the client side you have
this rich, structured
access to the data.
So this will also be turned on
for Maps Engine customers for
their data later in the year.
Not all customers have their
own data, but many of our
customers have a big
thirst and appetite
for additional data.
And so for these other data
types out there, beyond those
that Google publishes to our
Basemap, we're really excited
to announce that we're
relaunching the
Google Earth Gallery.
We relaunched this last week.
And this is Google's place to
organize and surface all the
rest of the world's
geospatial data.
So the data that doesn't
appear in our Basemap--
these are additional layers that
maybe don't make sense to
include in our Basemap for
typical consumer users.
We intend to surface all
the rest of the world's
authoritative public data in
the Google Earth Gallery.
And what's so cool about it is
it's built on Maps Engine.
And so all the maps in it that
you discover are accessible
and serve kind of via all
these Maps Engine
capabilities.
So you can easily view
it in Google Earth.
You can bring it into a Google
Maps-like front end.
You can actually get embed code
to stick it right in your
blog or your website.
And then you could also get
access to the JavaScript.
Actually take those layers in
those maps and put them right
in your own mapping
application.
So we're enabling developers, in
this case, to get access to
all these great, additional
layers and bring it right into
their maps.
And if you want to learn more
about Google Maps Engine and
the Gallery, you can go to a
session tomorrow put on by
some of our sales engineers.
Not all data is static
though, right?
The Gallery Maps Engine is
largely around contextual
layers that you style, and
that you can view in the
context of a map--
maybe update them periodically
through APIs.
But there's just tremendous
amounts of data in this world,
geo-located data that's
dynamic in nature.
For instance, the locations of
people or teams of people, or
animals, or packages, or
whatever it may be.
There's just a lot of dynamic
data out there.
And the IDC actually reports
that they anticipate, by 2015,
over 1.5 billion employees in
the world, in the global
workforce, will be mobile.
They won't be at a desk, they'll
be out in the field
going to job sites.
And there's just no easy way,
today, to manage that.
It takes a lot of effort to
build a mobile application and
have a server that can take
those locations, render them
to users and to administrators.
There's just no simple way for
organizations to manage this.
And so, earlier this week, or
last week, we were really
delighted to announce Google
Maps Coordinate, which is an
out-of-the-box, simple solution
for businesses to
equip their mobile
workforce with an
application on their phones.
And to provide the workforce
with tools and capabilities to
capture data in the field, to
share that data with the
central organization, and for
that central organization to
kind of manage those assets and
dispatch them to job sites
and other locations.
[APPLAUSE]
DYLAN LORIMER: And you can
learn more about it at
maps.google.com/coordinate.
Coordinate is actually built,
though, on top of a new API
that was built from the ground
up to really support this
notion of rich, comprehensive,
asset tracking applications
built entirely out of
Google's Cloud.
Historically, developers
building asset tracking
applications have had to have
their own database and go to a
lot of effort, essentially, to
store the locations of assets
in the world and to render
them on a map.
And so, with the Google Maps
Tracks API, this is a great--
this is an opportunity for us
to really rethink what a
perfect asset tracking API could
be for our developers.
And it was purpose built from
the ground up to store the
locations of your dynamic
assets in the world, to
provide for query capabilities
on them, store their history,
provide some visualization
capabilities, and otherwise
let you manage those assets
in Google's Cloud.
You can group them into
collections, you can define
geofences and be alerted when
they enter/exit those areas.
And this is going to launch to
trusted testers right about
now, and will be available
later in the year.
So, with that said, I wanted to
pass the mic here to Peter
Birch, who's going to talk about
Google Earth and the
future of 3D.
[APPLAUSE]
DYLAN LORIMER: This doesn't
work very well.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER BIRCH: Thanks, Dylan.
And as you can see we also have
a great talk coming up to
learn more about our Enterprise
Solutions.
So those of you who are actually
got a chance to see
our event a few weeks ago, we
talked about a lot of great
new things, including the next
dimension of Google Maps.
And in that, I actually talked
to you about coming soon for--
on Google Earth for
Android and iOS.
And just to get straight to the
punchline, today I'm proud
to announce that this is
available today in the market
on Android.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER BIRCH: And will be coming
very soon for iPhone as
well, an iPad.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Throughout history, we've
pushed boundaries to expand
our view of the world.
Today a new frontier is
at our fingertips.
Introducing a new way
to soar above your
favorite cities in 3D.
With the Tour Guide,
exploring the world
has never been easier.
Take flight in Google Earth
on your mobile device.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
PETER BIRCH: And with
that, we are--
one second.
So here we are.
This is Google Earth with the
latest version 7.0 that's in
the market today.
And let's just dive right in.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER BIRCH: Now one of the
things that we've always had
with Google Earth is that--
with a lot of our Google
products like Google Search
and Google Maps--
we've really--
we want to help people
find information.
And in Google Maps we wanted to
help people find their way.
Well, with Google Earth,
we really want
to get people lost.
We really want you to go out
in the world and explore
because that's really what the
wonder of the world is.
And that's what we try to
bring to our users.
So with that, we've also
introduced this fantastic, new
feature that we call
the Tour Guide.
And what this is, is actually,
for any given view, I can just
open it up.
It will give me a list of
locations in the current view
that might be of
interest to me.
So let's take a look and
see what we got here.
So let's, for example,
click in on the
Massachusetts State House.
And then again here, you can
see some useful information
showing up on the screen.
And it's actually taking us on
a little bit of a tour here.
And I can close that.
And let's go check out
Boston Common.
So today we have approximately
a dozen metropolitan areas
that are going to be live which
include pretty much all
of the San Francisco Bay Area,
we have Boston, we have Rome,
we have Tampa, we
have Charlotte.
We have Bryan's favorite place,
Lawrence, Kansas.
We have Portland.
That's just a start.
By the end of this year, we
expect to have coverage for
over 300 million people and
that's not the end.
We're just going to keep growing
from there because
we're really excited about
bringing this new 3D image
technology to users
around the world.
And if you want to learn more
about this technology, we have
a blog post out on the Google
Lat Long Blog right now.
And also.
If you go back and look at our
next dimension of Google Maps,
you can see some more
information about some of this
fantastic technology.
And with that, I'd like to bring
up Brian McClendon to
wrap us up.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN MCCLENDON: Thank you.
Thank you very much, Peter.
Am I on now?
Testing.
So, I wanted to thank Peter.
The Geo Team at Google has been
working extremely hard on
many projects.
Today, as you know, is one of
the big days at Google where
we get to launch many things
that have been in the works
for a long time.
But the amount of work that our
team has put in to make
this and all the other launches
you've heard about,
both here and on
the main stage,
possible, has been amazing.
I think we have the strongest
engineering team working on
Maps today and I'm extremely
proud of them.
To add to that, he announced
that we have the 3D imagery
available on Google Earth
in the store today.
We also did, just right now,
launch GMM 6.9 which has the
offline Maps that was
also talked about.
So think, we've delivered on
those two major launches.
And I would like to--
get the slide back--
coming momentarily.
And we'll talk about the rest
of the GEO Track because we
have a lot of teams that want
to talk to you, in much more
depth, about what we've done and
help you understand how to
use some of the features.
The animated symbols is just
incredible, I think from a
programmer's perspective.
I'm so excited about using that
because it allows you to
visualize large amounts
of data.
So offline Maps available.
And the last thing I want to say
is, we're trying to reduce
all the dragons.
OK, it's my fault.
We're trying to reduce all the
dragons, but there is one last
dragon that probably
we won't take out.
And so that, I thank the team
in Japan who did the April
fool's joke, it was
incredible--
getting Google Maps in 8-bit was
one of the most fun things
I think we've had inside
Google in a long time.
So with that, I'd like to say
thank you very much and go on
with the rest of Google
I/O. Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]